now I don't know if anyone's actually
noticed this before someone probably has
but did you notice that during the
Android Saga there's a panel where
Yamcha has just the wrong hair now I
know what you're thinking surely this
was just a small error on the part of
Akira Toriyama no big deal well actually
I think what's Happening Here is far
more interesting and it goes a bit
deeper I believe that from this moment
on Yamcha was replaced by an imposter
now hear me out I don't know if it was
poor ulong or whoever the [__] but given
this glitch in the matrix it's clear
that the Yamcha we know and tolerate was
never to be seen again after his hole
punching with Dr gero perhaps it wasn't
for perhaps it was something far more
Sinister and no one's talking about it I
mean have Yamcha and escrow ever been
seen in the same room before I think not